Good evening Dr. Zakir. Uh my questions
is about jihad. Is there any
possibilities to do jihad or declare
jihad in nation state country or secular
country or jihad just can be happen
by Islamic state or halifhat? That's it.
>> Can we declare jihad in a non-Muslim
country? I've done in 40 countries. I've
gone to USA and done jihad. I've gone to
UK and done jihad. I've gone to
Singapore and done. I've gone to Italy
and done jihad. I've gone to Canada and
done jihad. I have gone to Australia and
then Jad I'm coming to Indonesia also
doing J. I'm doing J in India because I
did J in India. I had to leave the
country. So easy. You have to strive.
You have to struggle with your hard
work. I'm doing jad full life.
Mashallah. Very easy. You have to ask
Allah to help you and do jihad. Do
struggle. As I said the best jihad now
is convey the message of Islam to
non-Muslim. Try and convince the
non-Muslims in USA, in Canada, in UK, in
Italy, in Singapore, in India. Try and
convince them. Inshallah many people
Allah is giving his ayah.